hallo mein name ist luke hat meine
lieben freunde da aber die werbung
direkt abgehakt wir schauen uns heute
meine damen und herren gemeinsam einige
der krassesten optischen illusionen an
das hier ist das erste bild das wir uns
anschauen und zwar steht hier ist großes
pick up and down the squaire filmhof
also wir sollen jetzt einfach mal hat es
mich verarschen für mich verarschen das
ist so ein video degas
das ist ganz normal bild esa mal bin ich
der einzige der denkt dass ich das
bewegt oder habe ich ihnen meine augen
schwächer weil kuba
was machen wir allerdings direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten bild hier und zwar
steht hier in die circles action die
motion lässt
sammer
aber okay das bewegt
auch wieder ein video
ich komme gar nicht klar egal war aber
weiter mit dem nächsten bild hier steht
der harz an bord moving der unis ihn das
doch nicht wahr ich hoffe dass wir so
rüberkommt dass ihr gerade sehe aber die
die schieben sich von links nach rechts
die gaddafi an video
das hier ist das nächste bild every
thing that look like snacks am motion
lässt das ist okay also die bewegen sich
auch wieder von links nach rechts
ich weiß wo steht konzentriert euch
nicht auf eine schlange sondern schaut
die ganze zeit hoch und runter man denkt
die ganze zeit dass diese von links nach
rechts bewegen
das kann doch nicht sein dass hier ist
das nächste da sagen die dass es mit den
fischen genauso ist er real talk
die bewegen sich bei mir nicht
drauf schauen bewegen sich bei mir immer
noch die schlangen dato war das hier ist
das nächste bild hier steht lücke des
green lions und move your hair day move
wenn ein
durchs fenster rein schau dir denken
sich auch jetzt hat er definitiv
komplette verstand verloren which way
die swing sterling das ist nicht wahr
das kann nicht sein die das ist das muss
ein video sei der geist ist es ist ein
falsches bild
ey
leute ich für euch mal jetzt im
fullscreen die herzen ein auf dem blauen
hintergrund und ich war sein die hardter
actually of the same colour red also das
ist ziemlich lieder aus und das ziemlich
orange aber ja klar natürlich wenn man
nur auf diese hier auf dieser roten
sachen achtet und hier auf dieser roten
da kann man das er dann aber trotzdem
das ist so krass was man mit unserem
augen für streiche spielen kann hier
geht es darum dass das sie angeblich
keine spirale sein soll aber nicht
reinschauen
das sieht so aus als wenn das so immer
kleiner wird wir können hier lang gehen
mit der maus das ist das ist ein regen
der das hier wenn ich das hier lang geht
das ist auch ein weniger als 1000 fans
die ganze hier so kleiner wird lux
konvex models naja ok also soll konvex
aussehen das gegenteil im vergleich
kommt habe ich auf jeden fall ein
bisschen aufgepasst in der schule wunsch
das heißt das bild soll den eindruck
vermitteln als wenn es sich beugt es ist
allerdings es sieht auch so aus als wenn
das hier höher geht
weil das alles so zu läuft mit den
punkten ich will kauf
ok also sie werden von helles licht
kommt
[Musik]
janosch it
wenn ich hier rum chrysler
ich denke die ganze zeit dass das licht
auch schwand und heller wieder etwas ist
mir egal
[Musik]
das erinnert mich an diese street art
bilder die dann irgendwie auf den
bürgersteigen malen
ich kann nicht mal versucht den kreis
waren hatte jesse james templeton face
off from the screen okay also jetzt
gerade sehe ich nur ich sehe nur ein
chinesischen tempel
aber gut ich würde sagen ich bewege mich
mal weiter nach hinten und sehe mein
gott ich bin fast nach hinten gefallen
ich noch keine ahnung was man hier sehen
soll ich mal gerne in die kommentare
schreiben was wir hier gesehen habt aber
ich würde sagen wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten bild der letters an updated
es ist
natürlich degas doch das peter
vollschiff degas ich erkenne kollaps
gleich als nächstes haben wir hier ein
fahrrad und es soll sich an den neckar
die reifen
das ist doch natürlich
egal ich sehe auch schon das nächste
hier und meine mitspieler in die fresse
fliegt die uci will square gedding
dicker und dicker
ich sage ich weiß nicht welches video
ich sag nur dicker aber denkbar dass das
ist heute nicht mehr
ihr seht doch auch sie zu hause sind die
teile auf einen zukommen dass jetzt das
nächste event hier as amended optical
illusion switch weather girls herning
okay also in welche richtung dreht sich
die frau dass sie ist das ist das ist
das ist das 2000 jahre später
becker
da
da muss ich immer ganz schnell los und
beliebter es heißt dass hier der typ
geht da rein und geht steht dort okay
das ist wahrscheinlich einfach
angemeldet
als gottes looks like this body spending
okay also er sei
ich finde das so krass einfach nur die
zeichnen einfach nur lesen
kreuze rein und man denkt direkt dass
das komplette bild gewählt wäre dann
nehmen sie die raus und auf einmal ist
es wieder gerade tenue sleeping woman
steht hier
ich sehe da einfach nur einen mann
einen alten mann der schläft man soll
draufklicken damit man die sehe immer
noch keine frau
bin ich
mit
hey sieht er eine frau
also dass die sonne die
sammer entweder stehe ich komplett auf
dem schlauch oder ich steh komplett auf
schlag hier steht die frage can uci blue
hartz4 okay also ich sehe auf jeden fall
vier blaue herzen
aber wahrscheinlich ist es halt so dass
das ist
das sind verschiedene farben der ist
noch blut der only three cars und
chipping green
aber gut ich würde sagen wir machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten bild hier steht
gäste karneval meister also dass das
modul karnevalsmaske angeblich also die
frage wird hergestellt hier sehen wir
einen verblöden menschen der sie trägt
horst lenz der smashing hier küssen sich
zwei leute habe ich auch direkt erkannt
adis harting steht hier
ja
aber nur
oh mein gott
hoppla genau in die mitte vom bild ach
du scheiße wenn ich mein kopf bewegen
bewegen sie sich gott mir wird schlecht
wenn ich so eine scheiße sehe ich habe
auch voll auf meine hand hat gespuckt
das jetzt das nächste bild can use the
waves moving das kann doch nicht sein
das kann doch nicht sein das ist einfach
ein grüner hintergrund mit einer blauen
schrift drauf und man denkt dass da
wellen durch das bild durch gehen
das ist doch nicht deren ernst ich fühle
mich gerade einfach nur komplett dumm
als wenn meine augen die von sum
zweitklässler oder so und mir nun
allerdings auch schon zur letzten
optischen illusionen die wir uns heute
zusammen anschauen werden und zwar ist
es wieder eine frage which hart ist red
also eins dieser herzen ist auf jeden
fall roth das jetzt definitiv in pink
das jetzt eher so ein orange und ich
würde das ist ich würde ja sagen
safe der oben rechts es sind alle das
wollte ihnen videos meine augen sind
beschissen wie scheiße an der stelle wo
ich das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beendet meine lieben freunde wenn
euch diese optischen illusionen gefallen
haben das gerne mal einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und schreibt
immer gerne in die kommentare was ihr
bei dem chinesischen tempel gesehen habt
weil ich weiß nicht ob ich nicht weit
genug weg gegangen bin aber ich stand
halt wirklich fünf meter vom bildschirm
weg oder ob ich das irgendwie nicht
gesehen habe keine ahnung abonniert
gerne einen kanal falls ihr noch keinen
teil der luchse seit wird nicht mega
freundes kostenlos über pass keine
videos mehr und die sarotti 99 um 15 uhr
in den schatten
[Musik]